hello grammarians let's talk about the
progressive aspect so we talked about
the simple aspect as something that is
just the most bare form it's what you
see here I walk I will walk I walked
but aspect allows us to talk about
things that are ongoing and that's what
we call the progressive because it's
progressing it's going it's happening so
if we are telling a story and we are
inside that moment we can use the
progressive aspect so I walk becomes in
the present I am walking so the way the
progressive works is that it takes the
form of to be for whatever the subject
of the sentence is in this case I and it
changes the verb into an ING verb that's
what it does that's what the progressive
does and its effect is to say that
something is ongoing this is also called
the continuous aspect but I like to call
it the progressive aspect let's let's
try this in all the different basic
conjugations so we call this the present
progressive let's try the past
progressive so if it says I walked we
would just take the verb to be and then
put it in the past so this part doesn't
change the walking doesn't change you
would say I was walking likewise for the
future so we're not going to change the
walking part we're just going to put
this am part into the future which is
like so I will be walking that's the
future progressive so the way to
remember the progressive aspect is for
me to hideously butcher the writing of
David Mamet and tell you to always
remember your ABCs always be conjugating
and conjugating here is just a word that
means to put verbs in different tenses
and aspects but I really want you to
focus on the fact that we've got this B
and this ing so just remember B and ing
and that's how you form they're
progressive so no matter whether or not
it's happening in the past it still I
was walking so the part that changes is
the is the B is the verb to be I was
walking I am walking I will be walking
the part that doesn't change is the
walking and that's how you express that
something is ongoing that something is
continuously happening in the telling of
the story standing this will enable you
to master time you can learn anything
Dave it out